- We saw your boyfriend, Jonathan.
- [Zooey] Yes, yeah.
- [Kelly] Jonathan Scott
at the "Property Brothers."
He was just here.
- He had the best time.
- [Kelly] Of course he did.
'cause he was on the winners team.
- [Zooey] Yeah, you guys won.
- [Kelly] We won.
- We did.
- [Zooey] Yeah.
- I don't know that we should
play games together
again though (chuckles).
(audience laughs)
- Oh, cause you guys were like...
- We're very intense.
- You were like the winners
that brag on everyone.
- We were the winners
that definitely let everyone know we won.
(audience laughs)
- [Zooey] Yeah.
(Kelly chuckles)
(palms clap)
- Do y'all get like that?
Do y'all play games?
- We play games. We play a lot of games.
We love doing like escape games
and stuff like that, which...
- Me too.
- Oh, okay.
- Love escape games.
- Let's...
If you want to do an escape room.
- [Kelly] Yes. I already
kind of invited myself.
- Oh, yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
- That's why I didn't win.
- [Zooey] Whose ex-wife did it best. Yeah.
- Escape rooms are so fun.
- Oh, so fun.
- What is it like though? Dating a twin?
I've always wondered.
Do they mess with you?
- No. To me they don't look alike at all.
And their personalities are so different.
So like, to me, they just don't look like.
- [Kelly] Wow. Okay, love is interesting.
Because they do look alike.
(everyone laughs)
- You know what's so funny?
- Love does shine differently.
- Even before we, like before...
We met on "Carpool Karaoke".
- (giggling) I love that
that's where you met.
- And I was with my sister.
And my sister's like, "I
cannot tell them apart".
Like before we met them and I
was like, "what do you mean?
They look so different to me."
- [Kelly] Oh.
- So, even before I met them,
I thought they look totally different.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- So...
- Other than like, one
doesn't have the beard.
But, yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] No, totally.
- But, even without the beard.
- Like they, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah, no.
- They don't look alike. To me.
- You might be alone on
another island right now.
(everyone laughs)
- (laughing) See? Am I ever right?
- I always am on some island.
(Kelly laughing)
It just depends on which one. You know.
- [Kelly] Those are the most fun people...